you've been very uh uh uh you know
critical of
almost anybody in in in office you've
had some comments about them i think
that democrats and republicans both are
deficient
and let me explain i think the
democratic party has been too silent in
the violence in the cities
by black lives movement you know they
they should be more critical more
outspoken
and i think the republican party has put
on with a lot of [ __ ] with trump you
know his behavior was disgraceful
criticizing a hero like john mccain
or um you know colin powell
in death shows no judgment whatsoever
and so very few people other than like
mitt romney and a couple of others have
been critical of trump trump's economic
ideas were superior but his behavior to
bidens but his behavior was disgraceful
and the way i assess it unemotionally is
i know a lot of very decent hard-working
people that voted generous that voted
for trump and their vote was basically
motivated more because they feared the
progressives more than they fear trump
okay and my view is different we live in
a democracy there are 300 members of the
house 100 u.s senators
that can represent my interest and i
felt that i would rather take a chance
with them than put a would-be dictator
into a second term
where he have no allegiance to anybody
but himself
i do believe his behavior has been
disgraceful and so i voted for biden
and uh
i voted for biden very reluctantly but
with a vote against trump to be honest
with you and i think the saddest thing
for our country is a country of 330 odd
million people we had these two choices
disgraceful so who who are you excited
about for 2024 you live in florida you
got a governor here that some people
like yeah well uh i don't like his
anti-masking stuff
i would say i had
lunch the other day with joe manchin and
i i could support him but i don't think
he could run as a democrat he'll have to
switch parties i agree with him he
sabotaged the build back better so it's
hard for me to imagine the democratic
party would put him in the head of the
ticket well he said the state state of
the union address he sat with the gops
and he was in dallas texas recently for
a fundraiser energy industry it was all
gop fundraising he's got a lot of common
sense and he's got a lot of fortitude
he's been getting calls every day
multiple calls about changing his vote
and he hung tough
and so he i would support him
mike pompeo is going to run chris
christie from new jersey is going to run
now there's plenty of people on the
republican side i don't know anybody on
the democratic side that i would vote
for at this point in time newsom
uh i don't know enough about them guys
that's a star for them yeah yeah
that's a yeah give that look they love
you
he sent out a fourth stimulus check to
california to get it
yesterday for gas something 400 per
person that makes no sense to me you're
looking to discourage consumption you
don't lower the price no california
hadn't had net out migration for the
first time since 1850 when it became a
state in 2021 they actually had the
he's no longer governor but
cuomo
andrew cuomo said basically that uh
people are leaving new york because of
the weather
i thought that was a great comment makes
a lot of sense yeah and leave it the
last you know however many years and
decades but trump you think uh you think
trump's running
i had lunch with a very leading democrat
who said two things
very politically connected a very fine
human being i don't feel up but i don't
feel it's appropriate to mention his
name
and he gave me what i call good news and
bad news
the bad news was trump is going to run
trump's going to get the nomination and
trump's going to win i happen to
disagree with him okay the good news was
he said predictions and the presidential
outcome three years in advance have
never been right
it's so funny yeah that's the truth he's
a very leading guy a very major
philanthropist who's on tv like you at
quite a lot he did a great job
but
i don't think the
republican party will give the
nomination to trump when it comes down
to push comes to shove just like a
democratic party denied bernie sanders
they didn't want him to lead the ticket
how important are these midterms
i think it's a lead pipe sense that the
republicans are going to sweep
um
maybe that's what's keeping the market
up but i i think it's a matter of how
they're going to sweep and what the
composition's going to be and whose side
they're on because the republican party
is just as divided as the democratic
party is right now yeah yeah well
to divide a country if you enjoyed this
short clip click over here to watch
another short clip and if you want to
watch the entire episode the entire
podcast click here
[Music]
you